you did mention that that you thought
that an understanding of the way ant
colonies are able to perform incredibly
organized tasks might well be the key to
understanding human cognition
so these fundamentally distributed
systems so what do you think is the
difference between the way Don Knuth
would sort a list and an ant colony
would sort a list or performing
algorithm sorting a list isn't famous
cognition though but but I know what
you're getting at is well the advantage
of ant colony at least we can see what
they're doing we know which ant has
talked to which other ant and and and
and it's much harder with the with
brains to just to know how to what
extent of neurons are passing signal so
I understand that aunt Connie might be a
you know if they have the secret of
cognition could think of an ant colony
as a cognitive single being rather than
as a colony of lots of different ants I
mean just like the cells of our brain
are and and the microbiome and all that
is interacting entities but but somehow
I consider myself to be one single
person well you know aunt Connie you can
say might be cognitive is somehow and
it's yeah I mean you know I okay III
spike I smashed a certain aunt and mmm
that's done what was that right you know
but if we're going to crack to the
secret of cognition it might be that we
can do so by but my psyche note how ants
do it because we have a better chance to
measure and they're communicating by
pheromones and by touching each other
and site but but not by much more subtle
phenomenon like electric currents going
through but even a simpler version of
that what are your thoughts of maybe
Conway's Game of Life
okay so Conway's Game of Life is is
able to simulate any any computable
process and any deterministic process is
like how you went there I mean that's
not its most powerful thing I would say
I mean you can simulate it but the magic
is that the individual units are
distributed yes and extremely simple yes
we can we understand exactly what the
primitives are the perimeter is the just
like with the answer all in even simple
but if we but still it doesn't say that
I understand I understand life I mean I
understand it it gives me an it gives me
a better insight into what does it mean
to to have a deterministic universe what
does it mean to to have free choice for
example do you think God plays dice yes
I don't see any reason why God should be
forbidden from using the most efficient
ways to to to I mean we we know that
dice are extremely important and
inefficient algorithms there are things
like that couldn't be done well without
randomness and so I don't see any reason
like why God should be prohibited but
when the when the algorithm requires it
you don't see why the yeah the physics
should constrain it
you